dude you see how like over the last like
5 years all theing slot machines are all
like Dragon themed now yeah dude that's
how you get it it catches the eye you
know what I mean I'm like dude this is
my you know how many seu slot machines
I've
seen
like sh she slot Machin all the C shake
[Music]
machine welcome back to another very
special episode of careful boys today
you will not believe who we have over
here when you cut to this angle you will
see under the influence let's go yes sir
and it finally
happened dude thank you guys for being
here Jesus Christ you know what's funny
is the first point of contact we had was
Jeremy mhm and it's sad that he's not
here today because we've been chatting
for almost a year now you and Jeremy
have been talking yeah with B in the
[__] group chat what yeah I didn't
know that and we been trying to that's
their homie they have a their crew is
big oh [__] yeah we have one more host
that's Jeremy and that's the guy that
yall have been s we got six here all the
time they have 40 hey don't bring me
into this he he has a no all
though but I'm so glad that uh you guys
are finally here because I see you guys
been popping up for like these past
couple of years you I just be on
Instagram I'm like oh this is [__]
funny and then you know we have mutual
friends I think Tim was on I think Jimmy
um so it's it's pretty nice that we
finally got to connect yeah yeah dude be
honest when you see us on Tik Tok do you
just scroll I don't even use Tik Tok
that's what a boomer that's why he said
Instagram
Instagram [__] I'm getting replaced God
damn it he's reporting our account no I
don't I don't watch the full videos but
I do watch the clips that pop up and I
think it's I think it's hilarious that's
actually me that's that's commenting on
your page as JK news it's me oh really
cuz I oh it's Nick yeah no but we
followed you guys' page a long time ago
yeah how' you guys get started um so it
was me and Jeremy that started it and uh
we were running for like I think like 6
months worth of episodes before we met
him and we were like doing interview
based content back then so we
interviewed him like on the streets no
no no like like bringing them in I met
him on the streets but then we brought
him into to a home and we're like get
off the street and then uh and then when
we interviewed him it was just super
like he was like an interesting
character his interview blew up and then
uh and we're like we're looking for
another host so come on and yeah that's
Co that's tight and then I met her
through a Jimmy Zang video shoot oh no
way okay actually hated her at first cuz
she had to like play the role of like a
[__] like she had to come in and be
mean but Jimmy didn't tell us any of
that so we're sitting there like why is
this girl so [__]
mean he literally told me to go into the
trailer and just start roasting people
and I just thought I thought they knew
what I was going in for you know and
then when I started just like roasting
them everyone's face just went like the
[__] we didn't even know we were filming
we're literally like who is this woman
and why is she being hella mean to us
what did you roast him on um proba
probably his hair we were all in costume
can you imagine just some girl walking
in just roasting your hair's stupid and
I'm like nice to meet you too I guess
was it like a prank or something or he
just wanted I think it was just bad like
directing cuz yeah honestly just to do
it honestly cuz it was supposed to be a
bit like we're all in Cosplay like I was
M from Naruto and then uh yeah and then
my hair was longer back then so it made
sense when I found out they didn't like
me it hurt my feelings I was like I was
like what do you mean and I thought you
know I didn't do anything to you though
yeah yeah no in hind slight she didn't
do anything wrong but in the moment it
was literally Like This Woman's a [__]
D that's tight and then and you and
Jeremy have been friends for a really
long time no I met him so I did like
bartending Tik toks that was like my
first bar chemistry yeah bar chemistry
yeah appreciate that dope but uh but
while I was doing that obviously he
started like an Asian heart Seltzer
brand so he's like looking for
influencers to promote is it is it this
it is this nectar heart Seltzer unique
Asian flavors no we out for Taste Z it's
not calories yeah tell us about this and
then Anthony take a test all of them as
the resident alcoholic wait so none of
you drink but you D so this supplement
is also useless except for you so I'm
sad you want to pass this he's he's
going to need it he's going to need it
though this is for you though never need
this [__] do you have a supplement that
prevents me from turning red this if you
take enough of this the main active
ingredient is dhm and it's actually
probably the best thing for Asian glow
oh dude I need that is this new for you
guys yeah yeah yeah I dropped this May 3
months ago so this is like eight this is
like a I dropped a holistic supplement
company basically and uh super recovery
is our alcohol recovery supplement it's
like eight natural ingredients and it
fights like the negative side effects of
alcohol before you start drinking that's
smart why is this thing so heavy I it's
a glass bottle glass is cheaper than
plastic to produce strangely see bar we
have to learn from these because look
check this out we own companies but we
not giving them any gifts and [__] that
we probably could have gave them so
yeah it would have been on our show like
we would have been promoting you want a
13 in September t-shirt that's your
shirt that I gave
you he's Reed he's already Reed no this
this is actually I got to get your sizes
I want to send you some care
packages popcorn thing H oh by the way
this whole snack is Buffet whatever you
want whatever it's not our Brands but
it's been staring at that no I've been
staring at this I'm not allowed to have
spicy on the podcast cuz I fall asleep
what but like this is a different
podcast
so that makes you fall asleep like
anything with te like
chili should do a fall asleep epilepsy
Challenge and then you you usually fall
asleep when you don't eat right me yeah
I never fall asleep Oh I thought I just
saw an episode where you fell asleep no
no he did fall asleep y y y y I know
exactly what you're talking about bro he
yeah he fell asleep mid so we did like a
host interview for all you remember
because you were asleep it wasn't wasn't
Jeremy or someone saying something mad
serious at that moment like really
heartfelt and then you just had shades
on and you were just like I I will say I
uh I messed up
yeah but it's only happened one time oh
okay these guys are loving it they're
out here going that's yummy you like it
yeah I like I don't even drink but this
really good the melon flavor or the
aftertaste on leure that comes in and
you really feel the leing you're like oh
[__] this is really the melon on this
comes through let me try I don't drink
either I'm try it's bomb bro you guys
always not drank or like is this a new
we all tried and then got headaches and
said this ain't for us let's do Ecstasy
I get sleepy you got ecstasy yeah oh man
maybe that's the brand we should come
out with this is really good see all
these flavors are like very you can't T
Al take this before you even water what
is this if you get headaches when you
get hang like when you drink if you get
headaches it's cuz you're like draining
B vitamins while you're drinking so
there's like a a super be complex in
there yeah this video is brought to you
by super recovery go get yours if you
got the Asian glow then don't be a hoe
that's the brand name don't be a hoe new
tagline I'm making a whole new product
bro they've been whole free since
2003 I will say uh I did blackout last
night I also realized I blacked out last
night I woke up like damn I don't really
have did you guys have a event no we
just went to the club just is that why
you guys were late today yeah I'm sorry
it was it wasn't me I swear yeah it was
all Esther she was the only one that
didn't go out and she caused us to be
like so take three of them take three
yeah three is a serving size I like how
you guys are just popping pills from
strangers and we just met them dude can
I get the mango I want to sip on that I
want to try it do we only bring those
three
flavors mango melons my favorite then Le
what inspired you to make this beautiful
comp and the graphics are pretty sick
dude like it's like samurai champu or
like some anime stuff going on there
have you ever uh heard of the nft
project isuki yeah oh that sounds so
those are isuki on there it's like a an
nft collab yeah and it's like one of our
investors that's his specific IP like he
owns that and that's the fun thing about
nfts is like once you own the one piece
like you own that IP you can use that in
your business or whatever so yeah so
that's the print on that can I ask you
guys how you guys are so smart and know
how to do all kinds of [__] like this
and investors I just heard the word
investors I don't got no cuz we've been
in business for quite some time but I
feel like we keep making mistakes we
don't got no investors or no one that
believes in US you guys could easily get
inv in what like opening gyms or like
what specifically yeah what do you you
have a gym yeah but I got to invest my
own money that I still don't have back
well basically I'm I'mma step out of
this cuz I don't have a business yeah I
don't I don't know what I'm doing either
who talk take it away yeah but how did
you know to like like you know like you
got an audience and like let's create
products that are that feel organic to
you and yeah well uh growing up poor I
was like I need to make money in
whatever way [__] possible so I just
like I've been like basically reading as
many books on investment and and like
business as I possibly can but Jeremy's
the one that started nectar and I
learned a lot from him about like the
investment process cuz like Tech there's
so many people out there that like what
made me confident that we can get
investors or whatever is like looking at
the trash products that people throw
millions of dollars at I'm like if
somebody will give you $10 million to
build this app that doesn't even make
sense then like there's no way that I
can't find people that'll throw money in
my ideas that is true yeah sounds like
what we did we read the books Maybe two
of
them but threw them
away we spent a lot of our own money in
projects we were the dumbass that oh
this [__] product right here like [__]
we're just going to put whatever money
all of this stuff we're just going to
put our money in it let's do it what
were the what were the [__] products so
he read a book he's like you need
investors he's like I'm going to be the
investor he just reads it from the other
side oh [__] [__] the
middleman sometimes you got to do it
that was you stepped up man I am a
matcha tea peder really um we I I have a
I have a tea shop near UCLA called Uh
jie there's one in Roland Heights and
one in Wy Kei and one in oh there's a
bunch there's a bunch yeah there's and
he's he's a partner in it too we'll have
we'll have 15 open by next year which is
pretty cool we nine R I know you guys
were he was he hit us up to you're party
next to my office oh yeah for your
Hawaii event well you invited us to
after we were gone though yeah yeah and
then um investment
strategy and I told Jimmy I was like yo
if I was there I'd take you to the shop
and then he's like oh yeah I'm here and
I'm like oh [__] and then he just he he
was out party oh yeah Jimmy does that
something yeah I know he's being Jimmy
Jimmy be having the worst communication
sometimes yeah wait what is your matcha
place called Jun June be yeah it's it's
matcha they don't have anything with the
name yeah we don't it's not in the mall
right that one plaza where it is the
Royal Hawaiian that mug that mug says
June Beyond oh we oh you do have one
ah hey I mean you said you you have one
out here like why don't we can go on a
little field trip yeah do you guys have
that do you have the strawberry syrup
matcha is or is that we have a
strawberry matcha maybe I went there I
think I I was there oh no way and W Co
and it was so good we went three times
we went three what the heck that's my
store you went in y yes I went with
Emily and then we went um we were just
like okay we we should get a drink and
it was not
only buba Sho wait you forgot to mention
the official name on the teleprompter
right here that you're
reading j y Kik only I also like how how
the the cup was behind a
bottle it's not even on camera we're not
we're not anti marketing marketing bro
yeah we're anti- marketers dog no but
it's really really good it's probably
the best Mar I've ever had thank you
very that's so sweet that makes my hot
we he he paid me 20 bucks for it I'll do
anything for M now we need to say it
with more zest that's tight though I
mean this this stands out so much when
you guys had the first thing I ever saw
was really this I was like yo that's I
thought you guys had like a sponsor but
then the fact that it's their brand it's
so much that's the first thing I noticed
too yeah yeah yeah wait it's the first
thing you saw on the podcast yeah
because I was like because I thought it
was so I just noticed it and I was like
what is that drink because like it's
like a no-brainer like d why don't we do
that with anything but like he said we
just got Coke Bott promoting promoting
Tobasco
the fact that it's still on the table
yeah dude I moved a cup over here we
yeah I need to learn I need to what am I
doing here I don't know I don't know I
feel like you guys are killing it though
like you guys are legends to us so like
I was I grew up watching you guys so
this is this is kind of a surreal moment
shirt show them the shirt throw it
promote it hurry up hurry up promote it
do you remember and you have the shirt
underneath a different
shirt I don't know when this video is
coming out but that's a sneak peek wait
did you get get that from Tik Tok like
there's a Tik Tok is
that what the [__] we got investors for
this Partners $10
million no I do I do remember that Arc
also wait there's no way that no one's
ever approached you like can I throw
some money at you guys to build a
product they just don't understand that
that's what they're trying to say they
all they do I think they they start and
then they see all the [__] [__]
content and the way we say things and
it's like maybe that's not good part
they do I'm just
sming a lot of our projects I like to
keep it in house with friends and family
and also cuz I feel comfortable losing
their money but VC money and strangers I
don't want to touch I don't want them
involved and they'll com Fort you too I
feel like yeah they'll come for you and
your friends they'll if you lose a
couple dollars from them then you go oh
that was tough huh yeah that was tough I
remember what nfts were popping I lost a
lot of my friends money
yeah story in this room yeah bro what's
the most money you lost on crypto or
nfts I I don't think I made any money on
nfts so I think I've spent now to date
like I've lost probably like 10,000
close just overall in nfts yeah I don't
invest in um nft but I do invest in
gambling she's made more money gambling
than I've made in gam what's your game
you go to Vegas a lot a lot yeah indie
cinos or like are you Vietnamese too no
I'm Korean Koreans gamble a lot though
why did you say that like you're
embarrassed no no because because
Vietnamese people like they learn how to
gamble when they're younger and I
started late degenerate parenting yeah
no but in the PO poker clubs around
California I think it's mostly
Vietnamese and Koreans that are the
Asians there I I see a lot of old old
Korean dudes there I never see Korean
people in Vegas gambling but I see a lot
of like Chinese people and Vietnamese
people lots of Vietnamese Vegas has so
much like good Vietnamese food because
of like all the Vietnamese people that
live there to gamble M dud you see how
like over the last like 5 years all the
[__] slot machines are all like
Dragon themed now yeah dud that's how
you it catches the eye you know what I
mean I'm like dude this is my you know
how many [__] seu slot machines I've
seen I'm like all the [__] Shake SL
machines all the C Shake SL Mach all the
Grandma's playing on love it love a
pretty face do any of you guys gamble I
only like group gambling what do you
mean problem so like I wouldn't like
just go and play Blackjack by myself but
if we all go to the craps table I'll go
crazy if we all go play poker I'll go
crazy and I can play for a long time
don't lose hell of money but if it's
just by myself not really you get the
itch right now huh black blackjack's
[__] I love Blackjack I've also never
made money gambling either so like
there's just yeah I mean if you give me
your money I can gamble for she like
taught me how to how to gamble once and
then I lost all her money what's your
what's your game Blackjack and bakarat
oh I need to learn how to play what's
the most you ever won most 25,000 W [__]
I like the immunis shot that's tight she
like most lost
26000 no true true yeah damn but they
take most of your money so how much did
you play to win 25g
26,000 I kidding he was he was right he
was right but it's what you know I want
it you know so that's bakarat or bakarat
yeah if I had that money on the table oh
I would have a [__] heart attack holy
[__] Bak the highest odds to win right
yeah yeah it's like almost 50% hella
Asians play backck yeah cuz it's fun
like everyone on the table is working
with you you know what I mean well
that's like with Blackjack as well I
like C too yeah yeah exactly but like
you want to go with the flow so like if
someone is doing uh dealer like then
everyone's doing dealer you're not going
against other people so like it feels
yeah it feels like a group have y'all
played that um it's a Vietnamese like
New Year's game where it's a big two
talking about with the [__] Dice and
the [__] crab and [__] yeah yeah I I
don't know what it's called but well no
it's like six different pictures one's
like the rooster one's the crab one's
like the giant par thing and then it's
not diced like numerical it has an image
of each one so when you roll it you're
like piece lands on that or whatever you
just put is it like Vietnamese Laria
kind of that sounds fun yeah are you
Vietnamese chinese vietnamese chinese
vietnamese my parents were born in
Vietnam but my grandparents are Chinese
oh his wife Filipino yep oh thank you he
said it as a
dis before you think he's
great he said it all quick too why
little like he snitched these guys got
Latino wives
dude Latin lovers over here both of you
guys and we got gingers Ginger table I'm
Filipino uh my girl's Australian yeah
damn
yeah I never got propped for that ever
that feels nice props Ryan over here we
give props for that everybody wants to
have sex with a kangaroo I'm I'm in that
boat you got a Latin girlfriend I've had
many Latin girlfriends I'm single right
now but yeah usually my exes are all
like we are painfully single I have a
question for Bart so how I was like why
just me what the no how is it okay so um
how did you how did you end up dating
your coworker because I'm on the same oh
we were actually together first so we
kept it secret for that long yeah cuz
like in the back in that in those days
um she was just doing her own job and it
was just me and Joe and then we just
slowly needed her to come and help out
and then we realized it's actually
really good when she is single cuz then
people are more willing to she was our
Honeypot like she was our CIA agent that
got the spies she was a spy so so easy
for her to like make contacts get
people's numbers and then kind of like
link us together and we're like the guy
try to [__] her and then they're too
late you're already on the show you're
our
friend don't be weird so we kept that
operation we need start implementing
this strategy you guys need a honeypop
wow so what I'm getting is we're going
we're going to the club I'm too late
because I already started working with
this person and say their in full full
full last name first last name oh um
she's trying to back Jeremy basically
yeah yeah Jeremy but oh you you and
Jeremy could do this little late I guess
you and Jeremy why is it late it's late
because I mean
we should have been together before we
started working you know I think it's
what mean are he this or no yeah yeah
where is it are we are we here what's
the problem you it down we're here we're
here that's a real Arc like you're
trying to bag him currently does Jeremy
know this um yeah does jery know this I
feel like he might know this is good
conversation he might know yeah yeah
we're not sure if he knows or not every
single what's the weight of his heart
you just like constantly compliment his
drink you got a neg him I think yeah
neing usually the way like these are so
good did you try making a keimach for
him I madean him food he said he likes
it well he's Korean as well right okay
kind of I guess like that's K to K
though that's easy K to k k to K is
common sense though your family's going
to accept it yeah yeah it's compatible
is he a bad boy is he a what is he a bad
boyy what a a bad boy like a g no not a
bad boy g b boy what's a what's a b boy
B boy it's a bad boy he spicy like you
boy Jeremy think of that right take the
exact opposite that's what Jeremy is
he's a very good boy sick whenever he
leaves his house really he's a Bubble
Boy and and second of all he wears a
pink wig to advertise his drinks which
was the we guy the Weg guy which is why
I'm in love with him oh have you said
have you said that to you got to drop
the L bomb right away yeah what is he
I'm so confused like I love bomb him all
the time but what do you what do you
like about that the the pink wig the
Bubble Boy what do you like about that
uh I mean you know I'm a woman so I like
to take care of people and so the the
fact that the fact that he's always sick
makes me like yeah my my heart you make
good soups make good BM broth for him no
I don't cook like that okay she can
order on door I sometimes send him food
really yeah he says thank you but he
what's Jeremy's problem how come you
don't maybe you're love vomit him too
much what's his deal maybe you got to
hold back yeah maybe you got to go hard
and then just never talk to him for play
a little hard you can't and then start
making out with these two yeah
yeah just for the tactic though just I
think jealousy works for the No No we
got to start we just learned mess with
the boys we just learned the strategy
we're going to use we're going to we're
going to use you to get new guests on
the show and that's also going to make
Jeremy jealous oh that's smart it's a
win-win situation all the new guests
give him a pink wig yeah yeah like let
me just see how this looks on you oh my
God it's so much better than Jeremy
every guest y you wear the pink wig so
much better yeah just say that wait hold
up this drink sell me this right now
okay this is this is what I did okay so
he wears a pink wig to the store to try
to sell drinks so I went to the I I put
on a pink wig and I sold it with him you
got to go purple wig yeah and that that
didn't work go no I thought yeah I
thought if I went that far he that's
kind of creepy let him chase you maybe
he needs to be you know he you need to
be a prize for him to capture so he has
to chase you now what do you think he
would I do need to do that respond to a
slab in the face yeah I don't know he he
flirts a lot with other
men dress a little more you know Tombo
wait you're saying he wears a pink wig
and he flirts a lot with other men got
the homies though yeah yeah my Bo with
the boys
dude he likes boy BOS if you're not
flirting with your homie like what not
random men not random men not random men
and are you sure it's this or is it this
sometimes I wonder that's good but but
come on you guys true right we got to
strategize flirts with men more than
women you know when guys suck each other
off it's not a 69 it's a L7 L7 L7 is
[Laughter]
[Music]
crazy